hi good morning how are you good morning
carlos
of course it's not morning where you are
now for me
of course yeah this is just the way
things are this is just the way things
are right now
right crazy well you are
you are proposing the future in this
film that is
you know different from what we're
experiencing now but its own very unique
thing what was your
take when you first heard of the idea
for what bliss was going to be
at the very beginning i didn't really
understand it before i read the script
he was trying to explain it to me
and uh he would get
so extremely technical mike
he would explain it to you in a way that
it made you believe
that for that it's a very big
possibility that
we are living in
in uh how do you say oh my god i forgot
the word in a simulation
simulation that you could be living in
and there were articles by
scientists and all these however he gave
me another choice
um which is addiction
you know a delusional escape through
addiction
and so when i read the script i decided
this was
the one i i could understand the most
and when i started the film i chose
even though the character doesn't know
it as an actress
that she was drug addict that was
delusional
and very soon after we started
it was so weird it never happened to me
before
the character kind of took me over and i
completely understood it and believed it
and and i was like no no no this is real
this is real what she's saying is real
it was a weird experience
but of course the character cannot be
thinking oh i'm playing a drug addict so
it was it was a good thing but but it
was strange
what was it like going through that
experience with owen because you both
are on
sort of different sides of the same
strange concept did you have all these
conversations when you're on set and off
camera about
is this real are we here are we not
it became the joke it became a joke and
and
and uh and he was we didn't mean to make
the joke so many times but but is it
we would ask the director but is it real
or is not
and we would ask ourselves but is even
about other things and it was
it was very funny how many times we
repeated that and
um the thing is
owen doesn't always like to talk about
it so much
um at the beginning i wanted to rehearse
a lot and so did mike and
we got together for rehearsal and it was
so funny because he showed up and he
said
i'm hungry do you have something to eat
and i cooked him some mexican food and
he was eating it and going and when he
finished he said
okay that was great bye and we're like
no no can we just like
do some of the seeds no i'm good i'm
good i got it and
mike and i stayed there rehearsing
without
like mike and i just wanted to read all
the scenes and
he's so easy going and
cool and brilliant and we had
so much fun together and i am so
grateful
i talked a lot about that with mike
but i'm so grateful that i we didn't
overthink it
with owen because then you can go into
your head of course
well thank you so much for this time
that's it for for me but this was
such a trip watching this movie and such
a great time talking to you thank you so
much
thank you
you